the history of American policing has
been a system that's been at the
forefront of regulating black people's
freedom and after slavery their
citizenship and so it doesn't make much
sense to think about policing as a
problem of a few rotten apples because
the problem reaches all the way to the
root today calls for police reformer
everywhere but does piecemeal police
reform actually work if the past 100
years of investigations into police
brutality are any clue the answer is a
resounding no this is why reforming the
police has never been enough this is
Khalil Gibran Mohammed I am a professor
of history race and public policy at the
Harvard Kennedy School the truth is for
a century or literally 100 years there
have been intense official
investigations into systemic police
brutality to be clear we're only
focusing on investigations into the
police the modern police force in the
United States has been around for closer
to 200 years and that's not even
counting precursors to law enforcement
like slave catchers in the south we're
focusing on past race riots and
resulting investigations which have
proven two things one racism and
brutality is systemic within the police
force and two after repeatedly
diagnosing the illness we fail to treat
it over and over again simply reforming
the police has proven to be a futile
task let's review the historical
evidence we're gonna start in the middle
the civil rights movement 1960s dozens
and dozens and dozens of cities become
ground zero for the fight between black
residents and justice where police
officers were concerned I think the
police acted terribly absolutely
atrocious
I saw wanton beating of people who had
not thrown any bottles or bricks or
anything else were merely walking along
the street beating to their head were
bloody and they were lying on the
pavement
riots broke out in Los Angeles Newark
Detroit New York City Atlanta Chicago
Tampa Cincinnati and that's just naming
a few by 1967 the president at the time
Lyndon Baines Johnson called for a
national commission on civil disorders
the colonel Commission found that across
these various cities police brutality is
pervasive indiscriminate stops in
searches that police systematically
harass youths and they added that the
beat patrolman himself is expected to
participate and to file a minimum number
of stop and frisk or field interrogation
reports for each tour of duty a black
social psychologist named Kenneth Clark
testified before the Commission Clark
was astounded that the commissioners
themselves seemed to have very little
awareness of how so many opportunities
to fix policing had come and gone before
Clark tells them I read the report of
the 1919 riot in Chicago as if I were
reading the report of the Harlem riot of
1913 island-wide of 1901 three of 1965
it is a kind of Alice in Wonderland with
the same moving picture we shown over
and over again the same analysis the
same recommendations and the same in
action and those reports Kirk mentioned
they all did sound the same look at
Chicago in 1919
systemic violence took place in the wake
of the stoning to death of a 17 year old
black boy named Eugene Williams he was
swimming with his friends in Lake
Michigan happened to cross an invisible
color line that color line extended from
the beach into the water and when Eugene
Williams crossed it white beachgoers
stoned him to death police on the scene
refused to help the black people of
color they enforced segregation and
black American demand for justice was
met with white violence a wave of
violence directed towards new black
migrants in their neighborhoods pulling
them off the streetcar shooting at them
on the Stoops of their own homes the
violence finally ended after days and
days of rioting the governor of Illinois
call for a Blue Ribbon Commission the
first one to look at systemic police
violence in the United States of America
the investigation pointed out that
police were part of an ecosystem to
enforce those lines of segregation that
protected white interests criminal
justice officials admit it as white men
in law enforcement that they and their
rank-and-file officers profiled
stereotyped and treated african-american
suspects differently and the
recommendations did not lead to systemic
change in fact they led to more racial
turmoil in his testimony Clark also
mentions the Heartland riots of 1935 in
1943 so let's go further down the rabbit
hole to the Great Depression Harlem it
was a young African teenager who had
gone into a local store where he'd been
accused of shoplifting rumors circulated
leading the crowds to believe he had
been beaten by police or worse even
killed in response the community rioted
they were responding to systemic
discrimination and Prejudice where
police officers were expressing the
racism of white New Yorkers against
black Harlemites what the Harlem riot
found out in its investigation about
6,000 arrests more than 90% of them were
for nonviolent mostly status offenses
disorderly conduct suspicious characters
open containers all the things that were
being policed but in fact represented
people living in a low-income community
having to do the kinds of public vices
that wealthier people or whiter people
in this case do behind closed doors but
the mayor buried the report and it was
only because of a black newspaper the
Amsterdam news that the report and later
became published which is how we know
what was in that report in the first
place
Haarlem write it again in 1943 after
police attacked an african-american
soldier who was defending a black woman
before the event proved to be a boiling
point after unending injustice we have
to remember that the numbers of
lynchings of african-americans in the
nation was growing by the thousands such
that by the late 1940s the number had
topped more than 4000 recorded lynchings
and yet no one was ever punished for
that mob violence another Blue Ribbon
Commission another report pointing out
systemic racism and brutality in the
police another failure to enact
meaningful change looking back from
where we are today to the Kerner
commission report it is an astonishing
echo that police officers then were
incentivized to show their productivity
by systematically harassing African
Americans that is what we find in
pattern and practice investigations that
really began in the 1990s fast-forward
to 1992 after the police's videotaped
beating of Rodney King and their
subsequent acquittal by a nearly
all-white jury African Americans took to
the streets in what is now called in LA
rebellion this public outcry eventually
led to the creation of the pattern and
practice investigation it's essentially
a spur stop version of a blue-ribbon
Commission's of the past so the federal
government can prove that there is a
reason to investigate constitutional
violations or they can use the power of
the purse by pulling the budget from
those organizations the idea was that
unlike the inaction of the past the
Justice Department and the local police
would agree to a consent decree finally
leading to reforms the situation in the
LAPD was so endemic and so bad that it
was under consent decree for nearly a
decade that meant the police department
was having serious delays in
implementing the agreed-upon reforms
it's also true that even after it was
all said and done a leader of the local
ACLU also pointed out evidence that Dana
collective or continued racial
discrimination within the ranks of the
apartment when we look more closely at
places like the Chicago investigation in
the wake of the killing of laQuan
McDonald or the Ferguson investigation
in the wake of the death of Michael
Brown the system that those
quote-unquote good people were working
in was fundamentally discriminatory and
violent towards too many people in 2014
Michael Brown was killed by a police
officer Michael Brown's body laying dead
bleeding out for four hours on a hot
summer day brought into Clear View for
the residents of Ferguson that black
people's lives truly did not matter what
did the resulting investigation tell us
the Department of Justice found
overwhelmingly substantial evidence of
racial bias among police and court staff
in Ferguson was that African Americans
were systemically harassed and assaulted
primarily to raise money for the city
these citations were putting poor people
in a cycle of debt for the purposes of
extracting them from money
Chicago 2014 laQuan McDonald was shot by
police officer jason Van Dyke 16 times
according to the dashcam video laQuan
McDonald was in fact walking away from
the officers when he was shot what
happened in Chicago tells a story that
shows that this was never just about a
rogue police department not only did Van
Dyke lie in the police report but the
officers on the scene supported his
story it turned out there was a massive
cover-up I'm angry because our kids are
being murdered and it's being covered up
it eventually led to a massive
demonstration that yet again police
officials could not be trusted to rein
in police officers when they themselves
actively committed crimes or covered up
for others the Department of Justice
investigation found African Americans
were subjected to 10 times more uses of
force against them than their white
counterparts they also noted that 98
percent of recorded complaints against
police violence had resulted in no
discipline for
mayor rahm emanuel at the time said this
report did not reflect the good work of
the vast majority of police on the force
and whether or not that's true the
system that those quote-unquote good
people were working in was fundamentally
discriminatory and violent towards too
many people Sandra bland Brianna Taylor
George Floyd Philander Castillo too many
lives have been taken with so much
evidence over so many years of the
failure of police to police themselves
police reform is going to continue to
fall prey to institutional inertia to
police unions who refuse to participate
in any serious discussion about the fact
that they have defended officers and a
culture that can't be called anything
else but racist when it comes to
african-american lives now when you hear
calls for fundamental change or
defunding the police you'll understand
why activists are done fighting for
piecemeal reform or leaving it up to the
police to police themselves we have over
a century of evidence showing that that
doesn't work we need to create a new
more just policing system rather than
trying and failing to reform a
systemically racist one
[Music]
you